in the conversation about the repeal
and/or replacement of Obamacare there's
this premise that Obamacare is imploding
the Trump administration likes to say
Obamacare is in a death spiral I've been
super clear with you for years that
Obamacare has major problems namely it's
a gift to the immoral status quo of the
for-profit insurance companies and
industry you don't really need to go
much further than that there's a major
there's a really significant list of
criticisms of Obamacare but according to
the Trump administration's own data it's
just not true that Obamacare is
imploding and urgently needs to be
repealed it needs to be fixed as a
symptom of the broader problem that we
have in our country around health care
but a death spiral is the complete wrong
way to be approaching this we now have
data from the Centers for Medicare and
Medicaid Services now that's part of the
Department of Health and Human Services
that is now run by the Trump
administration we have data from
Obamacare from 2016 and it turns out
that those insurance marketplaces
established by the Affordable Care Act
we're actually pretty stable the right
likes to sell you the horror story of
some single mom with 22 kids who works
at Burger King and his 12 pre-existing
conditions and she's the only person
going to the exchange and she's driving
up the cost of everybody's health
insurance but the truth is that the mix
of healthy and sick people who signed up
for insurance through the marketplace in
2016 was pretty similar to the mix in
2015 premiums have been trickling up in
total in sort of aggregate average but
recall that premiums have been
increasing in cost for a very very long
time both inside and outside of
Obamacare exchanges that's just what's
going on with our system doesn't really
tell you anything about whether
Obamacare is imploding so Obamacare is
no panacea and every time I have to
defend Obamacare I need to make clear
that I think Obamacare is only even
possible
in a horrible system where we have
employer connected for-profit health
insurance it's a train wreck right and
there are specific problems with
Obamacare some people make too much to
get subsidies or marketplace plans but
they still can't afford insurance other
people have opted not to enroll anywhere
because it's just too expensive and
they're paying a fine and still having
to pay for health care out-of-pocket but
this is according to Trump's own Health
and Human Services data which rejects
this idea that any day now we're getting
to this cliff which will explode a death
spiral of the Affordable Care Act and
this actually is part of why Republicans
might be moving in the direction of
saying hey if we can't pass a
replacement Pat let's just repeal the
Affordable Care Act and if we can't
repeal the Affordable Care Act let's at
least starve it of funding because then
we'll have a death spiral which we will
cause this is basically if it won't fail
they will kill it and then say hey we
had a solution all along which Democrats
obstructed which obviously wouldn't be
true to begin with and now you have
Republicans like Senator John McCain
saying that if the American Health Care
Act doesn't pass by the recess in August
then it's probably dead in the water
yeah then they may take the approach of
say Ted Cruz who says let's just appeal
the repeal the Affordable Care Act and
see what we can do in the next couple
years I wouldn't be surprised if there
was a third approach and Trump just says
well I fixed it according to my own
Health and Human Services numbers great
for me right can you imagine nothing
happened and then from goes hey listen
after all of those lies from Health and
Human Services under Obama it turns out
that I'm getting pretty good numbers
from Health and Human Services now about
Obama care and clearly it's because I'm
now the president so hey I did it I made
it work beautifully for everybody all
the guys take that deal yeah I mean at
this point it's probably the best option
for Trump and I've also been reading a
couple reports that say what's the last
day it's the last the 27th of July or
something is the last day of the session
and then House and Senate basically have
they get all of August off I believe
don't they well it used to be so hot in
Washington video that they'd give you
all of August off I mean now of course
you have the advent of air conditioning
but forget about that they do the whole
mom have fun
that the American right criticizes
France for being sissies and for having
this short work week and blah blah blah
and there's really nothing more French
than getting out of town during all of
August and that's exactly what our
Republican and Democratic elected
officials do here's the most important
thing to remember Republicans have to
take an outrageously extreme position
right now on the Affordable Care Act
because the Affordable Care Act is
already right-wing period I've said this
must be hundreds of times at this point
anything you do to move to the right
from the Affordable Care Act is going to
be extremely right-wing by its very
definition and now Republicans have sort
of shot themselves in the foot but rest
assured they'll figure out a way to
blame Democrats Hillary OPA ma or I
don't know liberal media for what is
shaping up to be a major failure on that
campaign promise